this episode as always is brought to you
by gray block pizza great block pizza
it's that comfortable Italian you know
regularity that's beautiful that you put
into your face you can get all types of
different toppings everything special
types of pies and they also have the
famous salad pizza you like salad you
like pizza well guess what
both they use can enjoy yourself gray
block get daddy a tow alright man
welcome and lady welcome let's go I'm
poppin right back with the same song as
last week a song man a song gets me man
the song gets me in my bones
[Music]
little town for me to slip step and
breathe and let myself
[Music]
[Music]
find a song and I will sing it just or
you I will find a song and I will sing
it just for you you know sometimes
people do that in your life you know
when people who you know it's rare that
I find that I feel you know that it's
rare that I find when somebody does
something in this just for me
out of just genuine genuine ASSA tea and
then you know it's funny when somebody
does something like that he hit you with
that genuine ASSA tea then I noticed wow
that's what that's like it reminds me
man I got a gin you know I got a genuine
us
I got a genuine eyes and I need to do a
favor for somebody who do something for
somebody and not even tell them not even
you know not even say hey you know look
at this you know vest I just bought you
or let you know
look at these rollerskates I got your
cousin but just do it
send a box of unmanned unmarked box or
rollerskates to somebody you know
sometimes you gotta just you just got to
do uh you got to do something for
somebody else
sometimes you gotta and I but I noticed
that when somebody does it for me anyway
I don't know why I started off right
there but where else you're gonna start
except in the middle and that's that's
where I am today happy day happy day to
you thank you guys for joining me man
that song just gets me dude right there
bro that thing
I want to eat that thing just breathe
this feels good it just something feels
good dude you know and that that's what
sometimes when I wish I had a little bit
of urban ah city in me when I had some
Urbanus you know when I had a little bit
of you know um
you know when I had a little bit of
maybe some Afrikaans down in my veins
because I just want to hit them yeah you
know I'm gonna hit I want to feel it you
ever see um you ever see our here a
black lady or black man they hit those
notes and you're like ma Lord that's
sound where did that sound even come
from
that's Steph Curry you know that that
that volume is Steph Curry because that
things coming from deep that thing is
coming from deep and I wish I had that
ability you know I got these but you
know I got these I have this small
ribcage and I got small lungs and the
doctor said that when I was born that I
had the had the ribcage of a large cat
and that you know and wick what goes
inside of those ribcage I got smaller
lungs so that's where I'm at you know
physically but thank you guys for
joining me today I hope your day is good
I hope whatever you're doing you're
doing it you know I hope whatever you're
doing if you pissed at somebody let them
know and get it out your life because we
going forward today what's up dude I
started a shitty diet and I don't even
mean that literally I just started this
diet I'm on this paleo Paley ologist
Paley I'm seeing paleo say Palio's Paleo
diet Paleo diet is that's you getting
back to the caveman ways because inside
of us even though we're all new fangled
you know we're running around here with
a cell phone and with you know North
Face coats and you know with um you know
kitty litter and all of these fancy you
know 21st century
technologies inside of us there's still
caveman inside of our genes it's you
can't deny that's in you that's limbic
that's at the root you know there's that
root of your humanity that is in the
base of your brain and that's that
limbic system and that's where where you
have those caveman tendencies and
cavewoman tendencies and look let's be
honest back in the day cave man cave
woman probably exactly the same really
because you had to think there was that
body Bush I mean the body Bush on a man
or woman you almost had to get up there
and you know part that hair you had to
get up there and search for that
pheasant to see what gender somebody
even was I mean now you see somebody in
the distance you can mostly guess unless
you got a man running around wearing
lipstick or you know putting on glittery
lotion on his neck or anything like that
then you might think oh that could be a
woman or if you have a woman who's you
know you know trying to have a special
type of you know what was considered
you're used to be considered a
predominantly male hairstyle you know
you got some women have a fade I've seen
women that you will shave a lot above
their lip trying to grow up that
mustache and I've even had women hit me
up because you know I'm rocking this
gender-neutral style and I've had women
hit me up about my hairstyle saying how
do they get it and also a couple of
ladies asking how they can grow a goatee
and I'm like look you know I'm not I'm
not you know I'm not out here
frankensteining you know I don't know
how to add parts or you know adjust the
you know the genetic makeup of your chin
but you know I can give you some more so
you know a couple of ideas on how to
catch some of this fade I mean it's just
a 1 into a 2 and then you got to kind of
fade it out towards the back whenever
you get right at the middle of your ear
you got to fade it out but but yeah what
is that talking about yeah but back in
the day I'm on that Paley arm on the
can I get this computer to work on the
Paleo diet paleo city I'm on it and what
it is is you can have meat you can only
have a few things you can have meat you
can have grapes you could have anything
in the Bible except for bread so you
know it's not a biblical it's not a you
know a god-fearing diet you know you're
not eating in the whole time you know
looking around for lightening bolts if
you [ __ ] up but it is a you know it's
just basic kind of stuff if you were if
you wanted outside of a cave things you
would find you can find you could have
fresh meat you could have berries
raisins
you could have honey can you have honey
you know you can a pure maple syrup
that's just got to be straight out of a
tree boy so I mean look then you'll get
hungry do it often if you see me in your
backyard and I'm you see a dude bent
down behind a tree my second node ant
Bank there you know
all right and eat no crash I'm back
there proudly trying to you know trying
to slurp a hit a maple out of one of
your uh I don't want to you're I don't
want to you're fun pieces of wood work
in your yard you know cuz you get hungry
that's the thing you get most hungry for
I find is sweeteners you know cuz I'll
make it through you know you can have
eggs you can have asparagus I mean you
can have actually they had one kind of
ice cream you can have but it's have
charcoal in it this [ __ ] sounds
something like [ __ ] that man but I did
it I just wanted to kind of challenge
myself with the paleo sand see if I
could handle what it was like to be a
caveman you know could I could I do it
if you know if suddenly everything shut
down and you know my high you know my
apartment turned into a [ __ ] made out of
rocks and my carpet turned into dirt
could I handle it
what would I go eat I mean you could you
know you'd have to try and catch birds
you'd have to have Rhett probably a
little bit of rat meat but Palio's diet
you know you can get those things and
you get those natural accoutrements that
just cater directly to your body so you
don't feel a lot of uh I'll tell you a
couple things I don't have a lot of
indigestion I don't have a lot of body
gas cuz I'm that type of dude I'll be
honest with you man I was um you know I
liked elect I was lactic acid and if I
had lactic air I was lactose intolerance
and it's not I know some people think
it's like a black lives matter type of
thing it's not lactose intolerance is um
you know lactose isn't a race it's
something that's in milk and if you have
it your body doesn't like it and see
your body it doesn't have a lot of waste
it's just yell at you and say hey I
don't like this so your body will make a
body gas and so if I had like if I add
lactic acids or whatever milk things
like that heavy creamer then I would
have body gas and that would make me and
everybody you know just it wasn't fun
but on this Paleo diet boy you nothing
you bro you can monitor my you could
modern or my little browser whole all
week and you won't hear it say a peep so
I'm really keyed down and I'm dialed in
on this Paleo diet and I'm feeling you
know you know what it makes me you know
what it does for me I'll say this it
makes it so if say if I want to go have
a snack I can't just go eat whatever is
readily available you know it makes me
think before I eat that's what it does
it makes me look at a couple of look at
the ingredients look at that you know
and so that's really one of the best
gifts about I've only been on it for
five days but you can still have fish
you can have salmon you can have celery
you can have what else can you have you
can have eggs I think I already said
eggs oh you can have meat so you can
have meat you just can't have bread so
you got it you can only have the middle
part of a sandwich so you definitely
seem like a [ __ ] pervert you know
dude one of my dad's friends this man
Larry dunt used to he would have a
sandwich and he had this dude had the
longest tongue ever and he hated us he
come over to our house and he hated us
he hated everybody
and I think the you know the Lord just
filled that man with hate and if you
heave if he was a um
if he was a piece of luggage and they
opened him up at TSA it would just be a
bunch of just hate blocks and they'd be
like oh okay this is just hate blocks we
thought this that you were you know
running um you know trying to cross it
you know move oranges or produce across
state lines you're good to go with these
hate blocks and Larry dunt had it was
just all hatred but anyhow if that man
got a burger he didn't like the bread
and it's one of the reasons why his
first wife left him actually because he
wouldn't eat bread and he would just get
his tongue around and just get it that
meat and it's almost like watching a dog
if you've ever hidden something from a
dog like a toy it's under the couch
watching a dog get in there like that
you know if you've ever watched seen a
long-legged a long tongued uh you know
Weimaraner or something or french
bulldog or anything like that if you've
ever seen it use its tongue to get under
that under the sofa to get something
that's how mr. Larry Dunn would get
around and he just get his tongue up in
there and try to get them whatever meat
was in that sandwich and that [ __ ] was
uh I mean watching it now I would
honestly say that [ __ ] might be a bit
ear rot ik not even in a homo not an e
not even in a homoerotic way or in a
homosexual way but just in the way of
that you know watching somebody try to
tongue the meat out of a sandwich
without eating the bread that [ __ ] is
damn boy that shit's sexy and we might
actually have to make a youtube maybe
we'll see if we can get some seniors to
try and um you know to try and excerpt
the meat out of us out of a sandwich
tongue only and I know that sounds
pretty bizarre but that would be a way
more unique type of pornography you know
instead of watching all this vulgarity
and people you know holding each others
butts open and
you know Hyde and silver wearing each
other's you know booties and all it is
and you know tying yarn around each
other's tits and all kinds of stuff
they're doing on the darknet if you had
just you know that kind of your rata
sysm where you was watching a senior
just try to you know tongue a couple
hits of um of mortadella cheese or
something out of a you know in between a
couple of pieces of of honey wheat
without eating the bread that [ __ ]
sounds crazy but also sounds really
really captivating and mildly sensual
and that's ways that we need to think we
need to think different you know we need
to try and think a little bit different
if we can and that's what this and
that's what this diet does for me I've
noticed I just really just really
realized it because I don't like it you
know I go you know I'd go up to Burger
King I'm like [ __ ] I can't have nothing
in here unless I have them cook a piece
of meat and just give me the meat and
one of those little cardboard to go
burger thing just meat only in there you
can't have ketchup you can't have a lot
of sauces that's the thing so if you
work real condiment jockey you know if
you somebody out there that likes to
wake up in the middle of the night and
just you know squirt a couple hits of uh
of that Dijon mousse tart into your jaw
then this isn't for you probably if
you're somebody that wakes up in the
middle of the night and likes a hot a
couple hits of of a blackberry jam and
your jaw then this might not be for you
but but if you're somebody that you know
that you wants to try something
different then maybe it is for you and
so I've been trying it you know and you
can have meats you can have I mean
there's all that gluten free [ __ ] you
can have all of that stuff but it just
has to be that way you know so but
basically you staying real lit you
staying real you stay real keen so now
when I go to the refrigerator I got to
think what I eat before I eat and that's
what I'm noticing is the greatest little
gift even if only do this for five days
I might not die you know you telling me
I'll never have another piece of wedding
cake in my life well I'm telling you
that I'm about to hack you up with a
dang saw
because I will have that but in the
meantime I'm just trying it it's not a
life sentence you can have oranges you
can have pears you can have all types of
stuff like that you know you can
basically have anything that's good for
you that you can find in a forest and so
that's why I'm Adam on that Paleo diet
and it's been it's been an adventure
I do feel you know I notice I'll be
honest with you straight out the gate I
noticed less bowel activity you know my
bowels have been more low-key probably
because I'm not eating as much junk I've
noticed a little bit of less inflation
in my body I have noticed and and you
know enough to already mentioned I've
noticed a lot less body gas and so in
that's enjoyable man I mean you know I'm
not trying to be vulgar here but
sometimes people like having body gasses
sometimes people don't you know it's fun
every now and then if you want a plane
and people think you taking a nap and
you've you know you launch a little air
baby and watch that thing learn to crawl
around the room under people's snouts I
mean that that that is just a joy but
also sometimes it's not a joy when you
and you you know you got a date over and
y'all snuggled up and y'all watching um
you know maybe you guys are watching uh
you know maybe you watch them Wally or a
league of their own with the base turned
up I used to do that sometime I'd have
chicks come over this was one of our
moves with ladies first you have a lady
come over right and look you meet her
outside but make sure all the doors are
open make sure your face is well lit
don't be that crazy to meet a lady by a
dark tree or some kind of [ __ ] like that
it's not safe so you meet a lady you
maybe meet her out front but meter you
know where she could see your face
don't take a candle out there by your
face that [ __ ] is old school you know
this ain't Abraham Lincoln dating this
is New Age dating so you just want to be
in an area that's NAT that's lit either
naturally or lit by some type of street
lamps or porch light but you meet the
lady outside let her know you're safe so
then you have the lady come over right
and you have
a you put on a little movie something
something set something kind of
something that shows that you're cool
with ladies a league of their own
that's about ladies um playing baseball
and you know some of them not really
experimenting with lesbian but no it's
not like that it's more ladies playing
baseball and wanting to hold down the
fort while their husbands are away
defending their country so that's a
great movie and and I'll turn the bass
up a lot of a lot of people don't think
this if you got some speakers at the
house or if you got car speakers but you
don't have a car right now because you
[ __ ] up on payments or whatever then
get your [ __ ] get your speakers put them
in the house and you know get a couple
12s or some 20s or whatever and turn the
bass up you put a league of their own on
with that bass up man you start and you
unleash a real [ __ ] fever in the air
because there's you a league of their
own that's the movie let's a woman know
you safe another movie you could watch
as a movie called up it's about two
grandparents and one of them dies and
one of them his house is almost almost
getting repossessed by balloons and it's
I guess it's like a it's like a way that
Disney or whatever Pixar kind of shows
you how a mortgage can work you got
balloon payments you don't deal with
your house gets taken away but what it
is is you can play you can play that and
put the bass up cuz bass that's foreplay
that's electronic equipment doing
foreplay for you you know cuz we don't
know you don't always have a lot of time
to touch your lady right so you need to
lose sonic abilities like um like bass
like bass cuz that thing that's that's
feeling all you know you get the
vibrations going that's touching your
lady everywhere a little bit lightly and
next thing you know her nipples are
stimulation you know full body if she
has body hair standing on end and that's
you know and then a lot of the activity
she's alert she got body alertness she
has body alertness and she has heart
trustworthiness because
you're watching up or you're watching
league of their own you got that bass
turned up and that [ __ ] is savage man
and that's a good way to meet a lady and
you know get a lot of the that way
you're getting free you know you're
getting a lot of free sensuality
occurring in the room because you got a
sexy movie on something that sentimental
shows your supportive of women and at
the same time you got the bass turned up
you know and that's that's creating a
sensuality to a sexual environment you
know that's creating that that caveman
doo-doo-doo-doo there's no crook there's
no crying in baseball ball ball ball
[ __ ] hire a DJ remix that [ __ ] boy
yeah well still well still well live
your life you can do it and that's a
great way to well have a date with a
lady right there but yeah back in the
paleo days think about that if you were
caveman everybody looked the same
everybody had just bush this was full
the own there weren't any haircuts the
only way you could get a haircut rip
your hair out of your body and you might
do that on your chest or something maybe
on your beard or something if you were
about to get married
or if you were really close to the fire
but nobody's straight ripping crotch
head out of their body so if you wanted
to know if somebody gender back in the
day you had to get up close and you had
to look around for that pheasant you
know you had to go on that two-handed
pheasant hunt get over there moving that
pubic hair and that P of its hair is
that stuff will hide everything you
could hide it do that you could hide
anything you want
they had a brother used to let me head
live near mania this huge froude he was
froude up and he would how to haul a
small stack he would hide a [ __ ]
bankroll up in his pubic hair so that's
you know that's a real that's a serious
turf
back in the day in Palio's times you had
to you had to get up close to somebody
to get to know them and see if they were
man or woman and that's uh so that's
kind of you know and so I think
sometimes when I'm on this types of diet
it makes you think about well it
definitely makes my senses more alert
and a lot of people know I talked about
this on Joe Rogan podcast that you know
I took I did a cleanse like like was
that three years ago two years ago and I
I was on day five of it I was at a Best
Buy and I was I was fainting for
anything to eat I mean I could smell
somebody's breath from from from eleven
twelve thirteen feet what did they have
roast beef like I could saw was just
alert I could hear somebody fold a piece
of bread from 60 feet away like what the
[ __ ] was that rye I mean you get soaked
because your body wants to eat your eyes
can see clear you your senses come alive
because your body is thinking I need to
survive right now and so I remember on
day five of that cleanse I was on the
lemonade
hot hot pepper cleanse and you drink
lemonade
you just have some syrup and cayenne
pepper and where I'm from dude that's a
[ __ ] hell that's a damn that's a
desert you know I had a couple of black
friends growing up that were raised on
that diet so you know that them boys
showed up for real every day because
that diet will I mean it made me so
alert because my scent I need to survive
and I remember being at Best Buy and I
started a zoned out and now there was a
Vietnamese gentleman there and he worked
there he definitely did he worked there
because sometimes people will walk up to
an Asian person and the best behind to
start talking to him and asking him [ __ ]
I've seen this happen 50 times and
they're like uh I'm just I'm a customer
and this gentleman worked there I saw
his name tickets had been and right when
I saw that I'm thinking you know vanilla
I'm thinking foods beignet I'm thinking
um you know I'm thinking I'm thinking
just foods and his name was Ben he
started talking to me I asked him a
question about something I was looking
to buy he started talking to me and next
he know I can't even hear him and I
started thinking I could it's gonna
sound crazy but he was Vietnamese very
small I thought I could eat him that's
how hungry I was I thought to myself if
everybody else in this store right now
turn the other direction for 40 seconds
I could [ __ ] eat little Ben I could
eat him and that's when I realized a
couple things about myself one that if
you have to you will if you got to you
will that could be anything that could
mean anything
and in this case it was if my body was
telling me my brain was telling me that
limbic system in the back of my brain
was telling me if you need to be a
carnivore a Humana for were you eating
humans were you snacking on neighbors or
whatever if you need to be that you can
be that if you need to be because
there's stuff inside of us that we can
do if we need to and that's why I said
I'll eat the [ __ ] outta little bin right
here you know right here over here and
it's in the Frigidaire section you not
freaked out take this do down between a
couple of [ __ ] dryers you know and
I'll have somebody somebody pass me a
side of tzatziki sauce and I could I
think I could digest a Vietnamese
gentleman back here behind these
whirlpools and that's where I was in my
brain I was like I gotta get out of the
store before I [ __ ] bite somebody so
it's just you know you don't know where
you can go and that's what I like about
trying this thing is because it's making
me I'm feeling new things about myself
I'm noticing new things I noticed now if
anything this teaches me to oh look at
the labels think for a second before I
just oh have that
because trust me I'm an addict and when
I want I will have that's but that's
where my brain is and so now it's neat
to be able to challenge myself a little
bit even a little bit just by doing some
of this paleo sand Palio's diet and and
you don't get all the the junk like
there's a lot of things we don't I don't
get them anymore my system you know you
know there's you know Sam sorbic acid
you know stuff that's in candy yellow
number 70 or whatever cheats and eats us
[ __ ] whatever you know unnatural
shits ice taluk SycE taluk acid set you
know they got if you look on me anything
it's all just a bunch of acid you're
like what is all this and then I just
have it and it's in me and then I'm
running drugs man I'm probably I'm a
drug mule but for some preservative
company you ever thought about that man
who am i to drug me before right now
I'll tell you it for Pfizer definitely
you know I'm sure I got a couple you
know milligrams acai Alice or something
you know about some levitra from India
this [ __ ] makes my [ __ ] legs sweat
makes my ass kind of a see my hips a
little bit ashy but at the same time
makes me spring up so it's a trade-off
but I'm definitely I'm drug mule and for
Pfizer right now you know I got an
antidepressant send me I'm on lexapro or
whatever I'm a dick you know I'm I'm
definitely a drug mule for Sam sorbic
acid whatever else is in a lot of this
[ __ ] I don't think I have any unnatural
food around me right now or whatever any
non Palio's and look I'm not condemning
you if you eat all that stuff and you
can O be okay with it that's good
I'm just trying something different you
know give me two weeks and I'll be I'll
have a [ __ ] box of runts in my mouth
you know I'll be you know I'll be you
know I'll be I'll be having other snacks
I'll be having gas station snack eree
but right now I'm just trying that so
I'm just sharing with you what it's
about am i saying them
different than you or that I'm better
than you for doing this [ __ ] that's just
what the [ __ ] I'm doing this week so and
I'm telling you some experiences I had
on it man that there's a lot of downside
of these things they don't tell you that
you might you know you might eat a
Vietnamese dude at the Best Buy
I'm praise God I don't have a roommate
if I had a new roommate that I just met
off Craigslist or something Gang Gang
bruh I hope you hope you don't mind
silverware cuz if I was on a cleanse
the lemonade pepper syrup cleanse and I
had a new roommate off Craigslist
I'll carve that cat up at night cuz
that's it that's one of the side effects
you get so hungry that you don't know
what is something inside of you will do
you don't know and that's kind of you
know and that's what's almost exciting
because I get to feel these things what
happens when I'm not satiated huh what
happens when I'm not you know some of
this inflamed inflammation leaves out of
my my neck and my you know my thyroid
you know what happens when I let that
when I give it a break what happens to
me who do I become what do I have
different thoughts is it easier for me
to get up and get motivated yeah and I
do notice some of those little things
it's easier for me to get up in the
morning there's a little bit less
thought in my head oh maybe rest a
little more so just little things man
and I think it just comes from justic
trying something you know just trying
something try something that's it but
yeah I'm on that paleo stand I'm not
running around with all these I mean I'm
not drugged mewling this week for all of
these you know companies that make all
these preservatives I'm not drugged
mewling for them right now because I am
on Palio's Palio's whatever the [ __ ] it
is is [ __ ]
what is this sorry for the bad language
I'm starving brah no [ __ ] dude dude if
somebody in front of me right now we're
eating a damn muff and I'd curse them
out
if somebody drove by an ice-cream truck
I'll pull that [ __ ] out I'll
beat that dude with a bomb pop okay I'll
hide a chick out did it all take a Chico
stick upside some upside a couple of
wild [ __ ] head right now that's where
I'm at
so also that's another thing you know
with these diets comes propensity for
violence I'm out here like a stepchild
right now I'm here I'm out here like an
angry stepchild so you know where I'm at
but that's something that I'm doing that
that's going on with me that's what you
know part of what happened this past
weekend what else man I you know I met -
I met two cool people at the Comedy
Store this weekend a medical cool cats
I'm going to I don't want to tell you
this I might be going Australia and uh
in a week damn I didn't know if I wanted
to tell you but I just told you so I
don't know yet but we'll see we're
figuring it out and they got some comedy
festivals going on over there and also
one of my favorite entertainers ever
lives there and his name is Chris Lilley
and if you've never seen the show Summer
Heights High you need to go watch it
I missed it somehow and it's my favorite
is my favorite type of entertainment
it's just really funny it's really funny
and go check it out you can find it on
YouTube in some different areas it's
hard to find but it's called Summer
Heights High like part one or piler
would start there and it will be the
best show you've never seen if you
haven't seen it and the lead the star
the may and the creator everything is
this man Chris Lilley
and he's in Australia so if anybody
feels the need if they know if they know
him or if they or anything like that
reach out you know hit him up you know
because I'd love to interview him while
I'm there and maybe if he gets enough
pressure from people he'll do it but he
I don't know if there's ever been I mean
he's just like a DA he's like a diamond
he's like a humor diamond and he's just
that's where he lives out in Australia
what else that first song that we let in
on today wood that was shined by Bishop
gun and it was the same song that I
played last week and and I just like
hearing it and it just lifts me up you
know I'm gonna go back into it right now
for just a second
[Music]
[Music]
just that's it man we'll put the link to
that again and um and my bios and stuff
like that him you know again I had the
pleasure of one of my buddies who passed
away he was a mentor to me who you said
let me work on his farm his son is a
drummer in that band and uh yeah my
buddy passed away of addiction you know
and he was a special person man he you
know he sometimes you just need somebody
to just reach out and just like I don't
know so no there's just something nice
about somebody reaching out out of
nowhere or taking you on you know saying
hey let me tell you know let me do
something for you with nothing in return
that's what the man did for me
give me a job at his farm and guess what
he didn't need a worker he didn't need a
worker you know he gave me a job on his
farm and and it changed it you know it
changed I mean it just was nice it was
like oh I got somebody you know cares
and he didn't ask for anything in return
and that's that's the magic of the world
you know that's the magic of the world
and in that spirit man we talked about a
trickling Mickey last week and we've had
a relationship with him he calls into
the hotline a while back and you know
we've been in touch I got a text from
him today he and this isn't definite but
I shouldn't share but you know what I'm
sharing him keep some hope out there he
is on he is scheduled to get some lungs
tomorrow
so how crazy is that boy he might get
them new ballast bruh he might be
running around on them new fricken inner
titties you feel me the mayor titties
them lungs and so he said he'll know
definitely in the morning I'll read you
the text that came in he said bro I just
read wha no he goes surgery scheduled
for took oh donor just came in man
crossing my fingers new hitters that's
what he said
I said no way he goes surgery scheduled
for tomorrow barring that they're safe
for me and that no one else may need
more than me and that shows you what
those transplant lists are like I mean
here he is goes to bed and you know and
he don't know if when he wakes up in the
morning if somebody else will have come
along and something will have happened
to them and now those hitters won't be
there for him and guess who it is it's a
man who od'd who overdosed ah we're
living in a wild whirlpool army we're
living in a wild whirlpool but thanks so
much man we had so much the good
feedback from that Lepus ode last week
and I you know I just wanted to give you
guys an update on him and we'll keep you
posted you know and also I wanted to let
you guys know that on behalf of our
patreon group we do have a patreon where
we release you know extra footage and
we're you know I'll do like behind the
scenes stuff that's going on with me we
put out an extra episode each month on
there that is just on patreon and that
our patreon donated $250 to Mickey's
GoFundMe so I'm not trying to get into
the GoFundMe universe you know you know
we this isn't a world of like Savior
ship that we're creating here or
anything like that but you know this
thing just kind of expanded with Mickey
and so I just want to say like if you
you know we're not trying to get people
to donate for him or anything like that
but I do wanna let you know on behalf of
all of us that this past weekend we
dropped to 50 and you're like Tim you
couldn't go 300 Theo we ain't get it but
we drop to 50 on trick lung Mickey and
um and you know as things go forward
we'll see if there's other ways that we
can you know be supportive but but we
meaning all of us because that patreon
comes from our patreon supporters so
thank you guys let's get into this man
let's get into a little bit this episode
we had some calls that came in we got
some unique stuff going on let me tell
you guys right now that gray block this
episode of you know is brought to you
about gray block pizza as well this
episode is brought to you by the ridge
wallet and the ridge wallet you got to
start to wonder what
in your carry in your everyday carry do
you have that you still got that booty
lump you still got that old stagnant you
know that stagnant but pouch looks like
your looks like one of your butt cheeks
has a big dip in its jaw do you have
that because I'll tell you a one that
Daddy moved on to that Ridge and that's
that front pocket carry and what's neat
about it is and this is true look at
first I got this I was like I don't know
dude three days into using this thing so
easy and it just simplifies it I'm not
carrying around all this extra stuff you
know I put my my insurance card into my
phone the number of it into my phone I
still keep it in my wallet but you keep
everything easy in here it's the ridge
wallet and this thing much less chance
of getting pickpocketing not that people
are really getting [ __ ] pickpocketed
but dang if you live in that area where
people are you know out there checking
the back year Levi's to see how how they
can come up then that can end and that's
that Ridge wallet dot-com slash Theo the
link will be in the BIOS and all of that
and that's um and that's a beautiful
this thing is a special is made out of
carbonate spacecraft material so this is
kind of [ __ ] you see in space so if you
got your Ridge wallet out and somebody
that works for NASA walks by and they
look over at you now you know why this
Carbonite polycarbonite you know
everything rfid-blocking they can't see
you people don't know what's going on
this thing stop a bullet
so that's Ridge wallet right there and
you can get 10% off by using our code
now that's a pricey item I don't want
some of y'all thinking that that's a
regular you know that's it
that's a pricey item it's not for
everybody but I will say this that our I
actually use this and I really do enjoy
it and they got other stuff there as
well if you want to check it out Ridge
wallet comm slash Theo thank you guys so
much coming up some dates Australia is
not definite yet if so I'll release it
on my Instagram but it's close June 1st
through the 3rd I'll be at the Civic
Center in San Francisco California and
that
part of a comedy festival and that
festival is called sorry cluster fest
and there's a lot of huge artists on
there Jim Jefferies is on there John
Stewart
Amy Schumer a lot of different types of
comedians are on there
and finally they lettin the dog on there
so let's go out there and show these
clowns what's up now just know it's just
gonna be like a 15-minute set but
there's a lot of other comedians area
you can see so if you want to get out
there and see all of that as well I hope
to book some dates in San Francisco or
in the area coming up in the knee in the
near time June 15th and 16th I'll be a
Yuk Yuk's in Calgary in Calgary is in
Canada and it's a beautiful city and
I've been there before June 23rd I'll be
at Imbler Brewing Company in Bakersfield
California
if those tickets are up we'll have the
link on my website
July 6th 7th and 8th I'll be at levity
live in Oxnard California July 20th
through the 22nd I'll be at Charlie good
nights in Raleigh North Carolina
I'm still trying to add a Chicago night
here and we may be doing some stuff in
rural Illinois again this year I'm
waiting to find out just a lot going on
right now at the moment all right let's
get into a few calls you know we got we
had so many wonderful calls and messages
that came out I just want to say thanks
thank you guys for helping create this
little universe we're doing here I had a
gentleman reach out about emailing about
being able to help donate his time as an
intern you know it's hard I'm just I'm
trying to facilitate a lot of this stuff
I got some help from Chris Perez one of
our producers and Nick Davis one of our
producers and you know it's just but
it's a lot it's a machine we're trying
to keep it going so we're trying to you
know manage everything but at the same
time I just feel fortunate that you guys
have been patient and and that we're
sticking with this you know when I first
started doing this podcast I don't know
what the f I was gonna do you know and
you know what I come in here today
and I don't know what the f I'm gonna do
but but we keep doing it you know we
keep doing it and so here we are let's
get into this and we got Jack from
Cincinnati Ohio calling right now on the
hotline and the hotline number is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three and that's just a number made up
at different numbers and you can call
that number and hit the hotline if you
have questions comments thoughts or
responses to anything that involves this
past weekend as well as well you can go
to this past weekend or you can go to
Theo von comm and there's three
different ways to submit you can text
call or send a video question in to this
past weekend let's hear more thank you
for calling Jack I got a crazy story for
you from last weekend okay as you know
we have this past weekend contest where
every month you can call in leave a
voicemail try to keep it at about a
minute and tell us what happened your
weekend something great or something bad
make it make sure it was an eventful
weekend don't call them with some shite
ass weekend you know you didn't do
nothing y'all out there just you know
you and your boys smoking a joint
looking at a lava lamp
that ain't that's not a crazy weekend
this that's really just a gateway to
homosexuality but uh but every weekend
will give out a prize package as
somebody who had the best or worst
weekend and and Jack is sitting in his
right here here we go so I got involved
in what's called a vasectomy boom
vasectomy boy that's when they cut your
nuts off your dog man let's go children
and I don't want no home so I saw a
doctor had a procedure done pretty
normal
got done with that a few hours later I'm
getting settled in I'm thinking I'm in
for a long weekend of chilling out and
the whole thing went pretty pretty south
for me
whoo and it started south on you
probably bro up is around you nuts you
know I'm saying nuts oh really that's
the florid of your body.you genitalia
that's basically Florida
because it's on your body but it's kind
of hanging off and it's sweaty and [ __ ]
you probably a good place sometime to
you know you might find some cocaine now
near but uh wow so you had to vasectomy
and then you saying that things went
haywire here developed was called a
hematoma oh it sounds bad in the ball
region
that's some serious Dark Arts with your
balls blow-up the size of a bowling ball
Oh as you're saying that I'm thinking of
the girl uh Hillary Swank and Million
Dollar Baby just hitting that bag just
hitting that purple bag bra oh do you
making my dick crawl around right now
let's hear more and you have to go in
get another procedure done and get laid
up for oh three or four days in the
hospital be careful with that vasectomy
watch out for those hematoma they will
mess you up man they'll make you
thinking you don't want balls no more
well you still want balls and that's not
where your brain should go there brother
I'm not trying to correct you know
you've been through a lot obviously you
you know you can't have in one week you
can't have children and your balls are
trying to you know your balls are trying
to just metastasize out of your body but
you can still have children I mean you
can't you know here's the thing bro
maybe you need it you shouldn't be
cutting your nuts up just come somewhere
else dude you know and I hate to jump on
you like that and I appreciate the call
you know out of Cincinnati it's tough
sometimes living around Cincinnati you
know or even right across the river
there in Covington Kentucky or across
that yeah but you know maybe just keep
your seed like it is and just take
better care you know dude it's not that
hard the only time you can get somebody
pregnant is when you ejaculate so it's
not like you you know you know a
Shepherd has to watch a hundred sheep
you just got to watch one you know milky
sheep that shows up occasionally so you
know look I feel you definitely I mean
it sound like the worst weekend somebody
could have had but
that's what happened to you and we'll
put that into the contest man for sure
man I'm sorry about that though man I'm
sorry I can't a fat bro you I wonder if
you thought that maybe it was like a
higher power telling you man I got to
shut this you know I can't be
I shouldn't be cutting my nuts up you
know I shouldn't be cutting my nuts up
so and I'm sorry for even saying those
words altogether I'm sure it's making a
lot of people out there pretty queasy
but thank you for calling and thank you
for hitting the contest actually I gotta
let you know as well who the aprile
winner was because the aprile winner was
Paul from Boston who his tender date who
brought his tender date to a Joe Rogan
show and actually we actually thought
that Paul it was an alibi cuz he called
and said his date went missing she
ruined the show she was yelling out she
had to be escorted out he had to be
escorted out and that was his weekend so
Paul from Boston we will hit you up on
the hotline and send you out some this
past weekend stuff what else is going on
oh I saw this Kanye West stuff you know
everybody's all on Kanye West and he was
he was talking about you know first of
all Kanye is he's almost like a lab rat
in a way you know he's a he he has that
mental you know he shows up and he talks
about mental health and you can't tell
sometimes where he's coming from
you know he's caught up in that
Kardashian universe you wonder like how
much of that weird influence or how much
of that influences really just shaping
him in you know where or on shaping him
I mean he you know he has a you know he
obviously has some like Jesus complex at
times he's also been hailed like a
messiah in some ways a hero you know he
has a musical genius and a creative
genius really I think some people are
just creative geniuses like I've said
this about John Mayer before I met John
Mayer a few times and I've had some good
conversations with him and I think that
John Mayer would have been a genius in
anything he chose to do it could have
been painting it could have been comedy
he would have excelled at it at the high
level he just chose music some people
have that and maybe Kanye had that as
well or has that but one of the things
that they got on Kanye are that you know
a lot of people said over Kanye about it
remarks about slavery about looking at
slavery as you know at a certain point
that are people just enslaving
themselves by you know by continuing to
make that part of the discussion and you
know look I mean it mostly he's talking
about black slavery you know African
American slavery and I don't you know I
don't know I mean yeah from my
perception sometimes I'm like you know
if we keep dwelling stuck on if we keep
reminding ourselves of only the negative
parts then you know is it possible to
fully evolve you know it makes me think
I mean I get scared saying some of this
kind of stuff because you know I mean
you know Kanye the crazy thing about
this is Connie's not even allowed to
think without being reprimanded so much
in the public eye like let the guy think
let him so you know no he's a genius but
the second he says something that people
were like or that the the media is like
suddenly he's not a genius he's crazy
you know it's like well let him think so
what if he's wrong Oh
at least he's braving an idea you know
you know I mean look I could think you
know I grew up in a subgroup in a white
southern environment I could sit there
and say I'm a [ __ ] redneck and [ __ ]
this and you know and some of that [ __ ]
I do say but I don't let that be my
whole story you know Ben Carson a while
back who was you know he's the
Republican sleepy black that's what I
call him cuz Ben do ben Carson was he's
the doctor who ran who's now I believe
like the chairman of the HUD
organization or something or Housing and
Development
he ran in the Republican primaries etc
and he talked about oh he referred to
slavery one time as immigration as as to
how black people immigrated into America
or some black people most black people
and you know what I thought that that
was pretty brave of him you know I don't
have a you know I don't have a black
child yet I'm a one-day I don't know I
mean I could have a half black child you
know I have black friends if I have if I
had a black friend who was you know real
stuck on that mindset of I can't get
ahead I can't do this I can't do that
it's all because of you know it's all
because I don't have a chance because of
the color of my skin or because of this
or that I would try and not I would try
and help him not think that way entirely
you know I don't want them to lose
anything that gives them fuel I don't
want anybody to lose their history you
know I'll be damned up if I'm losing
mine you know I'm out here every day in
this place where you know they don't
want a poor white kid from Louisiana to
come out here who's not a redneck I'm
not a redneck don't call me that [ __ ]
[ __ ] makes me mad you know man do I have
a little bit of redneck in me sure but
I'm rural I just grew up poor and white
dude I don't know we're never read and I
wasn't redneck we didn't have a bass
boat we didn't have a rebel flag I don't
have any of that [ __ ] we definitely have
a bass boat the closest I have nobody
ever even took me fish and really you
know the closest I ever came to the high
seas was bathing with four kids I didn't
know one time and they were black kids
and they had an old man come over and
judging our bodies but you know I don't
that will always be a part of me but it
doesn't define me you know um you know I
wish sometimes that I had rich family
members that would help me out along the
way I mean I have some rich I have some
rich step family they never helped me
nothing we got the same daddy but they
never did anything for me at certain
points I hope you know uh yeah we did
want a little help
the truth is that I my struggle is
whatever makes me that's what makes me
you know I know I'm kind of just
rambling here and but but so what maybe
some people think Kanye's crazy what if
he thought for a second you know what
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna think of
just I'm tired of thinking of that I'm
tired to think you know about slavery
all the time I'm tired of being reminded
of it by movies you know it's great like
what if I just thought of myself as I'm
a black immigrant in America I mean in
some ways it's almost you know taking
the higher road maybe and look I get
that I'm just a white guy sitting in
here you know and yeah we need to have
black guests on and we need to talk to
them and we need to get a little bit
more information
I asked Deon Cole if he would come on
and talk and he never even texted me
back so you know I'll try to get some
you know I'll try to get people that can
have more of a perspective for us but I
try to keep an open mind you know I
certainly can understand what it's like
to be poor I certainly can understand
what it's like to think people you don't
have a chance you don't have a shot but
that's what also has made it that's the
only thing I have sometimes yeah you can
have a nice jacket or you can have a
nice car but dude if you don't have
anything on the inside you if you don't
have your struggle if you don't have
where you came from if you don't have
your story you know if those things
don't mean anything to you you know
you're not you're never gonna let them
go but at their times when I have to
bite my tongue and I have to evolve a
little bit if I go into these business
meetings and I just you know and I'm
like oh I'm you know I'm and I embrace
that anger side of me or that up side of
me that feel slighted that feels [ __ ]
over you know nobody ever gave me
anything
rich people weren't driving you know
rich white people weren't driving
through the poor white area giving us
[ __ ]
if anything I felt like rich white
people looked at me like I was a a
pariah like I was some I don't know what
Praia means but um but I was like oh I'm
not I'm not messing with that whatever
that's poor whiteness I'm not you find
me far from that like I was something
like it like David fake came by me they
were gonna catch whatever I had you know
and so that's that's where you know so
my mindset came from what if we all
forgave everybody for everything what if
a lot of these black leaders and
speakers got up one day and said you
know what we forgive the people that did
whatever they did against us Danny I
would be the boldest [ __ ] ever now that
would be very empowering where that
makes it tough to be able to do that is
the finances you know and it's and I get
it and that's why sometimes so the ideas
of socialism look you know some of that
looks it just if anything that the thing
that makes me think you know and I'm not
a socialist maybe there's a part of me
that is emotionally but people aren't
willing to give up their money you know
people aren't willing to you know we're
still transitioning from a colonial time
into a time you know where people were
taking over lands you try to take over
somebody's land man [ __ ] you can
you're in court and their land there
when they're telling you to get get your
[ __ ] Marmot tent off their property
you know if you try to plant corn in
your neighbor's yard or go over there
with an axe he's gonna [ __ ] you up you
know when they're gonna call the HOA so
times have changed but you know I think
I just you know I don't love how the
media jumped on Kanye immediately oh
look he's ants hide this and he's anti
that is he or is he if
if he's a genius if he's maybe here just
hear his thoughts what if we tried it
you know in the media just honestly bro
they live I'm so sick of how many times
they've led me wrong the media is full
of [ __ ] they don't know anything because
it's just the same groups of people they
always take the same groups of people
it's always they you know they're based
out of New York and LA what do they know
you know that's where their stories all
these articles are coming from they
don't know all they know is these small
little circles that are getting more and
more gentrified and not just gentrified
and I don't know that's kind of a white
thing like these cities but it's a money
thing Dawg you can't even get mugged in
Manhattan anymore
try to get mugged in Manhattan you can't
you gotta sell Queens shout out Queens
about Queens will still [ __ ] you up you
know but some of these other places
Brooklyn where Brooklyn at but where
Brooklyn at Brooklyn's growing a
mustache dude Brooklyn's listening a
Leonard Cohen baby
Brooklyn's just got an all hipster DUP
you know you know and I'm and look I
love that place I you know I go there
and perform at the Knitting Factory you
know with those boys with will and those
boys and they got a great crew but man
sometimes I don't know I guess I'm
rambling but what if we try it what do
you know you know I think in our hearts
we all want to do things that are right
but then in our pocketbooks is where we
get scared in the media works from a
place of our pocketbooks and I know you
guys are saying well you know what are
you talking about the new but look man
the news is always the news is just
scares people you know I think the news
you the news will say shit's bad go
outside shit's not that bad you know the
news told us there was not it was not
see our prizes it was 200 weirdos in
South Carolina
that's all it has there been a ton of
other [ __ ] no I do think that a lot of
these stories that help us make us think
and question stuff
you know the news say that everybody's
racist in everybody's just in that and I
was just in my small town in Louisiana
and I asked the teachers there and they
said that racism is not like it used to
be in this small school and that was a
that was one of the things that they
pointed out and hey you know what I like
hearing that
and so I don't know if some of the stuff
just makes you mad I don't know I'm
rambling let's go to let's go to some
other calls it's alright I mean I guess
my thoughts on her what if we try the
bread you know what if we how brave it
is to think differently into it's to say
it do you know especially in LA it's so
hard to say what you want to say because
you won't work these places won't hire
you if you speak your mind and you want
to talk about being enslaved you know I
told I was told my whole life you know
like you know you leave you know you
leave a place say you know you want to
be more liberal you go to California and
you take your dreams out there and you
got a chance you know
and I grew up seeing people like me on
television and being like oh man I got a
chance you know maybe I could end up out
there maybe I can make people laugh you
know maybe I could take the one thing in
my life that brings me joy which is
those moments when people are laughing
you know cuz I knew if somebody was
laughing that they couldn't be hating me
at the same time and nobody probably did
hate me but I hated myself so much that
I just thought they all did so I was
like I got to make them laugh because
they can't hate and laugh at the same
time your body can't do it so then I do
you know I get into that and I come out
to California and they you know and then
suddenly it's like if you if you're from
these places if you're from the Midwest
you're from the south and you know they
just look down on us but they'll come
there and take our stories in a
heartbeat
they'll come there and buy our stories
by our scripts you know they'll come
there and shoot a duck dynasty show
until they you know until until it does
is it making money for them anymore
then they'll burn it down you know
they'll use us as much as they want some
of these places so I don't know man I
look
I'm probably ruining my [ __ ] career
by saying some of this but whatever I'm
not I'm gonna be okay some of its just
frustrating sometimes because you get
here and that's not the truth everybody
isn't welcome everybody's story is you
got to fight so hard sometimes to get
your story out but that's the struggle
you know they'll never take it away from
you but if I go into some of these
meetings and I yell and I save I'm so
when I can't do that
I got to evolve I gotta say look life's
tough on everybody everybody has their
story
everybody has their struggle I'll keep
that inside myself and I'll just make
people laugh if I can because that's
what I came here for right and so that's
what I got to remember that's been the
toughest thing that's what I've been one
of the toughest things for me to
remember over the years I used to get on
stage and be so angry I was be out here
I'll be performing I'd be so angry that
I wasn't getting a chance and now I'm
grateful a lot of that anger has been
lifted I mean I can share I can come
here and talk to you guys and kind of
reflect and get back into it but a lot
of that overall has been lifted and
that's you know that's one of the
blessings of of life I guess
it's one of the little blessings of my
own I got to be grateful for that sorry
for this ramble man sometimes I'd you
know I just I don't know what I'm
talking about but I hate feeling like I
can't talk I hate feeling here's what I
hate feeling I hate feeling like it's
[ __ ] up for somebody to share an idea
because it's not the status quo because
it's not gonna get the most likes on
Instagram that day or cuz it's not gonna
you know
ocaña is a genius until he shares one
idea that people are like huh
maybe he's a genius you know maybe he's
not I'm not saying that slavery never
happened or that I'm not saying me that
[ __ ] but I thought it was really
interesting when Ben Carson said he
referred 205 even expanding her but he
referred to he goes when black people
emigrated to America and I thought
I was brave of him to say that because
that's brave a way to rethink a way to
repurpose the thing that's hot that
haunts you know ya slavers of one of
America's biggest sin you know but to
repurpose that and then go forward the
pride it takes to [ __ ] do that if you
tell me that that ain't brave bruh
that's that's and I'm not saying that's
right I'm not saying that's wrong but
I'm not gonna sit here and be afraid to
even talk about an idea or thought that
I have because then what is this what is
this podcast what are we doing we got
this call that came in man let's hear it
here we go what up to you this is Tyson
from Atlanta Georgia
just sayin them huge fan we saw the man
up show I got my wife and I watched at
YouTube hilarious
Oh Thank You Tyson I appreciate that man
yeah that's a special show if you
haven't seen it you can find that on
Comedy Central digital and we're hoping
that they're gonna give us a um a series
and we had so much engagement and
interaction I want to thank all our
listeners for that I mean it really
means a lot it was a blast
onward just touch my son so far actually
its first great coach pitch today and
instead of saying the team name on the
count of three we say Gang Gang so I
just wanted to let you know that that's
awesome man gang getting to them man -
that's - that uh that first grade
baseball team man and that's awesome
you're out there being supportive with
your son you know that's uh you know
when you when I hear even here you say
that man I mean it just makes me feel
something you know it's nice to know
that there's fathers and sons out there
just doing stuff even if it seems cliché
type of stuff throwing the ball around
but there's something inside of the
fabric inside of ourselves that that
means something to you and to your boy
let's hear more I'm turning 40 on Friday
so I'm trying to deal with that it's
crazy comes fast and you think I know
you're a couple years away but anyway
you know you feel young but you get no
you know that's it man we do we feel one
thing and our body's starting to fall
it's like you know something
is happening on the outside but thank
you so much man for calling calling in
and happy early 40th to you
let's hear a couple a little bit let's
hear a little bit more here here we go
onward what'd you say boy the country
causing Karsten from taxi
all right Carson thanks for calling I
don't have any cousins actually I do
have my brother have my father had some
I've linked up I actually have a cousin
but he's lit I'm not not joking he's I
think he's 80 like 84 years old but um
homeward I got cousins over there in LA
you got cousins over here in Texas each
side you know how it goes
I I don't really know how it goes man I
mean I you know I respect the family
tree and I know that that family tree
can get a little high me you can get a
little fine you down there and uh in
certain areas but let's hear more
Houston on to the goddamn Mississippi
anyhow bro
just want to say [ __ ] in I'm driving
driving everyday I'm driving all over
the [ __ ] place it's your spirit
that's [ __ ] holding me up it's kind
of like a spirit animal I think you're
more of an architect father
do different arctic foxes eats
occasional Vietnamese people at Best Buy
if that's in his food path and maybe I
could be part of that program let's hear
more brother and I just want you to ice
the world back to the south because we
just got this first kids rap out a
pungent half kickers and wifebeaters
[ __ ] like that you know what it's I mean
uh I appreciate you saying this some of
this stuff man
appreciate you calling in and both of
those calls taya the [ __ ] the Tyson and
Carson there we sometimes we just want
people to call the hotline and say who
listens to the show because we want to
know I want to know who's listening
because if I don't know who you are then
how do I know
you know then sometimes I don't know
what ears I'm talking to
but you know what the South does get a
bad rap and you know what it is
sometimes in the Midwest a lot of places
do and you know what it is just people
people are we are prone to make mistakes
I'm making mistakes right now in my life
you probably are too it sounds like you
might be drinking and driving around
actually Carson so that's probably
illegal
but you know people are gonna make
mistakes but yeah the South does it it's
like you know they definitely it's
always you know I mean a lot has been
made of racial issues and it's tough
dude it's tough being from a place in
you didn't do anything you know I didn't
do anything you know my grandma my my
family on my mother's side was from
Illinois and my family on my father's
side was from Nicaragua so I you know
I'm not coming in like that you know my
family didn't have any sand so enslave
anyone you know we didn't do a lot of
those sins of this of the area and
probably a lot of the people that did or
big businesses you know people that
owned a lot I had a lot of money in a
lot of land you know and who know those
people now probably are you know they
could be Rothschilds who knows that
where they are you know and if we do get
a bad rap we get a bad rap of idiots and
stuff like that but I will say this that
you know in some in some places we you
know there's people who don't want to
evolve and that doesn't help us that
doesn't help us have a good rap you know
there's some places of people that just
don't want to evolve and I think that
those are people I think those are both
of all colors you know I think those are
black people I think there's no white
people that you know there's white
person that wants to sit out in their
small house or their big house or their
trailer or their motorhome or their
mansion or whatever with their money and
they just want to say [ __ ] these people
they don't want to be part of the
problem they don't want to be part of
the solution they don't want to expand
their thought in any way and then
there's black people who want to
probably sit places and say oh well I'm
[ __ ]
you know I don't have a chance in the
world I'm just gonna you know I'm just
gonna take whatever easy way outs are in
the world
and I think both of those people in some
ways are guilty the exact same thing you
know and I think the mission for the
rest of us is is how do we get a word
into these people's ear you know and
really it's not even a black and white
thing really it can just be a rich and
poor thing it can be an awake and a and
a closed thing it's like how do you get
word to that person how do you adjust
their heart a little bit or adjust their
brain so it opens unlocks their heart a
little bit so they could think just even
brave to think a little bit differently
you know I'm reading this listening to
this book still called sex at dawn and
when I first heard it man they were
talking like a lot of anti-christian
stuff and things like this and it's some
of it her I didn't want to listen
because it hurts some of the fabric
that's in me I'm not I'm not a devout
churchgoer but I grew up in that world
you know in that environment where I saw
it you know I only have a few memories
of spending time with my father and one
of a couple of those are at church and
so there's little things that tie me to
that and I don't wanna I don't wanna I
don't want to I don't want to Russell
that fabric inside of me you know I
don't want to talk I'm gonna I because
you know that it just I want that to
stay how it is and be special and that's
but I you know but if I'm gonna think if
I'm gonna think bigger
and I'm listening to this book and
they're saying that you know we're not
supposed to be monogamous and we're it's
not in our nature but in my heart or
somewhere inside of me there's this
little picture of this family I always
wish I had them you know that my parents
were together and that we were all happy
kids and then I'm sitting there and my
dad's knee and my mother's wiping
[ __ ] jelly or some [ __ ] I should have
been eating off my face because even as
a young hitter I probably straight up
took that jelly jar to the dome but I
had this this this idea that I don't
want to alter and so I'm afraid to think
oh what if I'm not gonna end up in a
monogamous relationship
they [ __ ] with this little Norman
Rockwell picture I have inside of me but
now keep listening to the book and all
its gonna do is make me think a little
bit more it's gonna open up my my my
thinking it's all it's gonna do it's
gonna open it up some so they're not
gonna look at my Norman Rockwell picture
and say well how could this picture be
adjusted so it's not a sentence that I
feel like I have to live and it's more
actual replica of what my real true
feelings and heart are like and so I
listen so I try and listen but yeah I
feel you Carson thanks for calling about
that it's like you know the South does
get a bad rap but it's like when do we
forgive a place and move forward you
know and it's just like you know it's
like and every place acts like when do
we act like we're not better than that
other place you know it's like you know
Hollywood was all during the elections
and everything like we're all May
everybody's making fun of Donald Trump
and you know I'm Bernie Sanders and you
know people for being old and being this
and being adulterous and stuff like that
you know Donald Trump's on his third
wife yeah he probably you know he I'm
sure he doesn't have any marriage that
probably doesn't have a dull tree in it
he probably stays up looking at
pornography on the internet but you know
what's [ __ ] up that's probably half
the men in America I think there's a
weird place where a lot of people
related to him there Oh in a weird way
this dude I can run this dudes on his
third we know he's a pee every buddy
people know he's a cheat people know
he's as dirty businessman they all are
you know I don't know why I'm bringing
it to that but it's like I just when do
we start you know when is there a little
bit more transparency you know when do
we you know stop pointing the finger
because ha you know we point the finger
here in Hollywood but then [ __ ]
shyster whatever his name was was
jerking off and in ladies plants and
for movie roles we're all creeps we're
all creeps what are we gonna do about it
all right let's hear a little bit more
man thank you so much for calling
carcinoma word CEO Jason up here in
Washington it is Thursday May 3rd and
just give me a call man Charlotte's you
know they're slacking on your pimp and
homie
thank you for Jays thank you Jason from
Washington for calling I'm slacking on
the pimp and let me know more about that
Kat Betty I'm a delivery driver and I
look forward to when I first started you
listening to your podcast was actually
you were on fire and a kid which I
listen to because of Joe Rogan since
probably episode 50 with him and red van
on a couch anyways okay so you listen to
Joe Rogan since the beginning man that's
a beautiful brother home word get your
ass in gear can you let me down I look
forward to downloading your podcast on
stitcher and then listening listening to
them offline in my delivery truck
Thursday you got nothing up and when I
started listening to you you put
something up on Monday and then Thursday
okay you're right and I'm just gonna
stop you right there Jason and not out
of anger or angst and I appreciate you
calling brother and I appreciate you
being a delivery driver and and
downloading the podcasts in advance so
you can have them so you're not burning
up your megabytes while you out there on
the road on the road while you out there
delivering them hitters but Thursday
isn't guaranteed man I try my best
sometimes what happens to me is if I
don't like regroup a little then I don't
have anything to say you know it's like
you ever call somebody have nothing to
tell them some I'm like on Wednesday I
feel like that and so I have to not do
it Thursday you know and then sometimes
too I'll put a Thursday up on patreon
you know patreon keeps this show going
you know this show there's no profit on
this show as a business okay so just so
you know where this show is like as far
as a business mind as a business thing
and if it weren't for the people on
patreon donating money every month then
we wouldn't we wouldn't even be able to
pay for what we have going on and it's
been great and it's been good
and and I'm grateful so sometimes have
to give something just for them you know
and so that's where that's at but I
appreciate you Jason I appreciate you
being out there getting the job done and
working hard me work hard bro I'll say
this man you work hard in this country
you know you can you can have a good
shot now it but it is [ __ ] up when
some people don't even get the chance
because their environment is so [ __ ]
up that they never get the chance to be
at the starting line and that is a lot
of the heartbreak of poverty and I think
that's a lot of the heartbreak you see
of and a lot for me that's what I see in
a lot of like poor black and poor white
culture in America is you see people
that have just never had a chance you
know and I'm not speaking out of context
I'm not speaking for anybody Matt could
drive you to neighborhoods that I grew
up next to and drive you past friend's
house in my old neighborhood and uh and
you just know man the odds of somebody
in this place is gonna have a shot it's
gonna be slim it's not because of the
home but it's because of you know maybe
their parent there but their mother a
grandfather never had a chance that [ __ ]
abs that [ __ ] ebbs and flows right down
there through the bloodlines it's tough
it's green privilege man you know
there's a lot of green privilege out
there but thank you Jason burr : let's
hear a little bit more man we got
another call coming in here here we go
this is Caleb from the UK calling about
the Dark Arts homeward so you know the
cocaine I like a bit I don't that comes
on a weekend book not too much so it's
not not taking over my life so you do
cocaine sometimes on the weekends it's
not taking over your life but okay let's
hear more when that wouldn't also know
when it takes over you know I like a joy
Bona it's a dark heart so I wonder when
we think when when should stop you know
on it what should it take over I'm hard
to see oh the past weekend the Facebook
page and we need you
when you call come on Caleb thank you
for calling you said you're part of the
Facebook group and yeah if you want to
join that there's a great Facebook group
for this past weekend on obviously
Facebook and a lot of extra stuff goes
on there and our producer Nick Davis and
myself and you know we try and keep that
thing Wiley over there keep it wiling so
yeah go there and join that if you want
also if you get a chance man go comment
on us on on iTunes you know that helps
us a lot in iTunes show up in search
engines and all that
leave a comment it doesn't have to be a
good comment it can be negative but
still a comment as a comment so I
appreciate that if you can I'll tell you
this Caleb for me when cocaine was a
problem for me was when it started it
kept me from things that I knew were
more important to me you know I have
that story that's up out there
about when I ended up on the radio show
in New York in the morning and I
couldn't talk because I was so high and
and you know that night was fun and
[ __ ] crazy and the story's funny but
in that moment dude it was it was tragic
because here was a great opportunity
meant to get on the Opie and Jim Norton
radio show you know two men that I
admire and that night I went out that
night with my friends planning and
excited about going the next morning and
then here I was that next morning
showing up and I couldn't talk because
of cocaine because I couldn't control
myself
so that's when when I started canceling
some work meetings and stuff like that
because you know I'd gotten in bed the
night before at nine o'clock next Hino
got a text from somebody to go to the
comedy club or to the bar next you know
I'm at the bar next thing you know it's
9 a.m. 12 hours later and I'm high in my
bed you know I've watched all the
pornography in the world and I have to
cancel whatever meetings I have that day
or auditions or anything because I'm I
haven't been I'm I've been asleep
so that's when when it when it
outweighed something that that was part
of my original path because my original
path was just show up for my day and now
I wasn't doing that
my original path was to be on the radio
and be excited and be there and be
grateful for the people that had me
there and now and I'm not doing that
because drugs were just they were that
other side of the teeter-totter with
that bloke ain't on it was getting icy
and look I'm not telling anybody not to
do cocaine if you can do it you go do it
okay if you can manage it well go manage
it well handle it enjoy it but for me I
could not for me at a certain point I
could not one day might not be able to
again maybe so we shall see if they come
out with some like cocaine you know what
I'm saying give me a couple grams of
that a 5% yeah yo 95% uh
doctor soles foot powder okay man let's
see if we can get another couple calls
this this episode has gone on long and
here we go I talked about not smoking
last week and I went three days and then
I [ __ ] got in an argument a little
bit and and one thing led to the next
and I couldn't and I gave up and then uh
but here we did this right here
but then I smoked yesterday as well so
here we go Laura Laura Delphia what's up
Laura from Philly onward to show some
support for you and your equipment
smoking cigarettes I haven't had one
since I think the second week in
February dang so if today is May seventh
second week in February you're coming up
on Wow about 11 weeks I think guessing
and the main thing that helped was
finding other reasons to go outside if
I'm out with people or everybody's
hanging out all the smokers get to go
outside and go smoke so I decided why
not just go outside and not smoke go
outside walk around the block any reason
to just be outside and not standing
around smoking a cigarette Oh
so I don't know if you have access to a
yard or anything like that but a yard
the same prison boo onward Laura but
plants get plants be that nerd this
outside gardening is the best I started
doing it I have a little patch of land
out smack in my my spot in Philly and it
helps a lot I'm out there all the time
and it's a good space to think about
things you're not distracted by cell
phones or computers or anything like
that you're just out of sunshine I love
it I love that idea and I love picturing
you out there in your little garden out
there in Philadelphia in your yard and
that's a beautiful picture learn up
thank you for saying this you know I
used to get jealous of cigarette smokers
because when I worked at a restaurant
and I was a busboy and I used to [ __ ]
bust dude no I'm saying they got they we
needed they got dirty glasses over there
on Table twelve brother and I was there
in a heartbeat I would out bus everybody
Latinos anybody that showed up I was out
in those dirty dish streets so and I
finished a [ __ ] desert in the back
dude I go hide in the toilet with half
of a [ __ ] cookie and ice cream [ __ ]
Gang Gang that's mine
but thank you for calling you're right
you know I think I think the things you
really said or just get out get out
doors let that Sun hit you find a hobby
find something to put on the other side
of that scale because if all I got on
that side of the scale is a cigarette I
know that you know I'm gonna go do that
I'm gonna what's on the other side of
that scale what other reason am i going
outside for you know and you know what's
funny I think even you Colin I was
thinking about smoking later on tonight
and I think I might not now I swear to
God
because sometimes you just want to hear
about somebody else's journey in it you
almost kind of ruined it for me in a
weird way but in a weird good way by you
sharing what happened with you you know
you can do it I'm like [ __ ] I can't go
the rest of the day now Laura can do it
you know Laura with them petunias in a
yard
that bag you know with that little bag
that little back a little back strip of
land with them gladiolas on it you know
she out there with them azalea's with
them bougie million if she can do it I
can do it so thank you for calling that
is some good guidance I'm doing my best
you know I went three full days and in
the past two days I smoked that night
but just in the evening at the comedy
club let's take one more call man and
then we'll get out of here let's take
this one right here I had a couple of
echoes from Scotland and I would well we
got another Scotsman here and this is
this is crazy I didn't we turn into a
real international thing you know we got
somebody out there in East Texas you
know we got somebody teaching ball in
Atlanta we got beautiful Laura out there
planting them Pat young yes planting
those smoke free petunias and I don't
even tell you congratulations Laura
because dude I'll tell you this I've
quit cocaine trying not to ever smoke
because I most of the day I'll be fine
but it hits about 9:30 p.m. I'm at the
comedy club mmm and that's when it gets
tough and now we got some people call
them from other countries let's hear
more brother thank you for calling
sorry inspired Netanya I was gonna ask
I'm about to graduate as you saw and
there I'm not really sure what this what
did it afterwards and and stuff I'd ask
what when you were you know and you're
so early twice or whatever what do you
want to do because I'm always excited
jealous of people who have like you have
your comedy and defent people do
different things and that's one thing to
actually actually would mean be even
just to have one seems like it would be
it would take a lot of stress a lot of
things and I don't have a dream that I
don't know what do I do
man there is something about when
somebody calls for another country and
he's like I don't really have a dream
I'm not I'm not taking the piss out of
you there
I appreciate you calling man you know
you know I can understand what you're
saying
you know it's tough and you're young
though you're a young guy so you have a
lot of time and one of the cool things
about being young is that you don't have
to have that yet you know maybe some of
the thing could be that in your head you
got this idea that you have to have that
and if you don't have oh I'm gonna be a
lawyer I'm gonna be this or I'm gonna be
that that that makes you feel like all
no direction but man you know I love
being a comedian these days but there
were if I could take a year and go maybe
to a law school I think I would love
that you know I would love to have F you
know or start a coffee shop somewhere
and be a barista just excuse me meet
people all day man I think I would just
love that
if I could maybe go you know to school
for therapy and learn how to UM you know
listen to people I think I would love
that so you know I think you got to
embrace this time where you don't know
that's awesome man you don't know
anything can happen
possibility you still have possibility
and here's how you find out you got to
try do seven years ago our action
private not maybe nine years ago now I
moved back to Louisiana and I got a real
estate license and I did real estate for
like six months and I worked with a
buddy of mine whose house I used to live
at my friend beau growing up I used to
live over his house for a bit his
brother had a real estate thing and I
got into that for a bit and and it was
fun you know but this one went out
comedy one out over time you know at the
same time I was bartending I was you
know tending bar or basically a Mexican
restaurant that also sold liquor and I
broke a [ __ ] uh margarita machine
over there first
day at work broker like a $700 margarita
machine damn and that's I also like [ __ ]
man I can't but I worked there for a lot
you know I worked for six months and
maybe even a year I stayed there and and
it was you know it was what it was it
was good it was joy you know I made the
most of it and um and so you got to try
things man that's how you'll know you
got to try things but don't feel bad
about yourself cuz you don't know you
don't you don't maybe you don't not know
you haven't decided yet try and reframe
it man
you know cuz you sound like a nice
person and even by calling in I can tell
you this about yourself you're a person
that cares about yourself because you're
putting it out there you care about
yourself
so what does that mean you're very
caring so if you want a little clue what
who care what what kind of jobs could
caring people do well people that care
make good um nurses you know and I don't
know if I mean a nurse in America
nursing can be male or female I don't
know what did it what it is in Scotland
or teachers um you know therapists you
know people that are caring um you know
yeah you could do lawn care you know you
could work with Laura in Philadelphia
but you you have the ability you still
have anything and you don't know what
that's like man there's a lot of us even
sitting here doing you know I know I got
to go to the comedy store all week at
the comedy clubs and and I'm grateful
for it because it's what I like to do
but it's still my work you know I'd love
to have a man I would love to go back to
school sometime and learn like a new
trade you know I thought the other day I
would like to look I like to go look for
gold they got this man and um if Arizona
New Mexico who buried two million
dollars with the gold out there and I'd
like to go look for that but I don't
have you know I don't have that I don't
have that luxury so you have the luxury
of freedom and you have the luxury of
ability so I think you're gonna do
really great things maybe try one
what if so what if you're wrong you have
time so what if you take six months and
and take a class and you decide oh
that's not what I want to be I don't
want to be a town planner or I don't
want to be a you know I don't want to
run a bar good now you know two things
you don't want to do so now that that
indecisive world is a little bit there's
less to less options to choose from you
know I [ __ ] in college I didn't know
what was going on I kept jumping around
in different colleges because I wanted
to travel and you asked me what I wanted
to do I wanted to travel so I went to
say I ended up at seven different
universities and I traveled and I you
know and it was fun and you know I had
like 300 [ __ ] credit hours and no
diploma you know I took some of the same
classes four or five times because I
didn't know that that wasn't you
couldn't do it I didn't fail am i of
just any class I did good and I would
just take it again at the next school so
then I got to the account so finally as
like well dude you you know you got you
know 60 hours of speech and reasoning
level 101 and I'm like [ __ ] yeah and
he's like [ __ ] no so look man I think
you got a world ahead of you and um and
you you know get out there and give take
some chances man you got time uh what
else man
let's take I'll hit this one more call
right here and then we're gonna we're
gonna retire for the day here we go hey
what's up video this is James Emmerich
I'm from North Carolina Asheville hey
James Emmerich thank you for calling man
I'll be at Charlie good nights in July I
believe you want to come through there
sometime but uh onward and I just I love
this past weekend it's a great podcast
thank you dude you know appreciate that
man you know we're trying to make it
good and and in Chris Perez and Nick
Davis are so supportive and you know we
got you know my buddy Kevin best it
helps with the shirts and you know
larell down there in Tampa who runs
stuff and keeps you know listenership up
and there's a lot of neat people who
help but thank you
oh we're monogamy in general has brought
up a lot of questions to me
really especially recently with past
relationships falling apart wanting to
be more promiscuous and finding other
women to be within share relations with
you know you want that person to sleep
with then you want other things in life
too that just go beyond that maybe not
just sleeping with them but just a
casual sexual encounter and it's just so
shut down and pushed far down under the
rug for most people especially with
religious backgrounds that you shouldn't
be doing that and I just been reading
this book by Christopher Ryan called sex
at dawn and it just opened up so much
more I just like to know your thoughts
about monogamy well thanks for calling
man I don't know if you already knew
that I was reading that book or not so I
couldn't tell that in the call but
that's the best the book that I'm
reading listening to right now I'm
listening to it you know it's definitely
something that I struggle with you know
I do struggle with heavily with um with
desires mostly of you know of like you
know I don't struggle with desire to
love someone else you know if I'm in
love I don't struggle with it his are to
love someone else I just struggle with
you know sexual desires and you know
almost uh just a desire to act out you
know a desire to misbehave a desire to
mess something up for myself or to you
know but yes sexually yeah I think it
makes you question a lot you know
because we do you want this family
element and it feels like that's what
it's supposed to all be but but do our
behaviors you know or do our behavior so
so different that we do want to be able
to have Tris and you know still feel
that sexual thing I think it's rare that
people can feel the sexual you know is
you maintain a lot of sexual energy and
still stay in a marriage
I was talking to a friend of mine bill
I'll talk to him a lot he's up there in
San Francisco and you know he has that
in his marriage where there's still a
lot of good sexual chemistry and and you
know that's a fear that I have I have a
fear that if I mean you know in a
marriage will I be able to do that
forever will I be able to you know
remain monogamous and I don't know if
I'm really honest man I do not know but
I also don't know if that's because
there's something inside of me that is
off that I haven't healed that it's fear
because I know for sure that I want to
be in love no doubt about it
no doubt about it you know um I mean I'm
spending time with a gal now and it's
you know and it feels great you know but
but I do I do worry but well-well
monogamy something I'm gonna be able to
do my whole life you know and I don't
know and you know it does tie back in my
mind to this idea of what things are
supposed to be you know and also where
is it just too much pressure these days
with the technology I mean back in the
day the only other woman you saw maybe
you're at the store with your wife and
you see a woman across the aisle you
know squeeze a grapefruit and you go in
the truck and jerk off real quick tell
your wife you have to go to the restroom
or whatever you're going to look at the
whiskey but now that that is around
every corner
those women it's everywhere it's all
over it's part of our society sex sells
and it's out there so it's you know it's
tough do I think that I'll be able to be
monogamous my whole life and stay in a
monogamous relationship I don't you know
if I'm really honest with myself I don't
but also
no if that's because I suffer with you
know not only some intimacy issues but
intimacy of the connection intimacy of
you know trusting someone enough to be
able to be in love with them enough
where I don't want to act that way or
feel that way or were that I don't act
out sexually because it's me protecting
myself by giving me a way to not stay
present in my relationship and by doing
that it'll then trick me into thinking
oh because the relationship isn't good
for you you know or you know love isn't
ever gonna work for you so then my brain
will trick me and a will behave this way
over here or you know watch this
pornography or do this or flirt with it
you know this girl or act out sexually
and that will that will just support
what my brain is already saying you know
or that will give my brain proof okay
cool man we got to shut it down I
appreciate you guys for being here thank
you again to Paul from Boston for his
this past weekend story make sure to
leave a review on iTunes if you can
check out the this past weekend errs on
face face book that's our Facebook group
as well
Thursday's episodes are bonus episodes
we're gonna try to get them up when we
can we got a great guest coming in this
Wednesday and that is Eddie Bravo the
conspiracy theorist we're excited to
have him come on
so hopefully that should be up on
Thursday thank you to our callers thank
you to Jack who had the you know the
gonads that you know got really big the
big ballin out there thank you to Tyson
the softball coach in Atlanta
thank you to Carson from Texas who said
we are related thank you to Jason for
calling and asking about the Thursday
hitters
thank you for James calling in with a
question about monogamy and Caleb over
there in Scotland and the trouble with
cocaine when it's too much for you you
know when it when it when it's on the
other side of the scale
you know when the heavier side of the
teeter-totter has cocaine on it that's
when it was too much for me I can't tell
you when it's too much for you but but
that's when there's too much for me and
I do appreciate you calling sharing
what's making you hurt that's it man
wood if you want to call in this week
calling about monogamy calling about
that calling about how you managing it
how calling about you know what's your
fears were if you overcame it if you
were acting out in a relationship or
marriage of that kind of thing call in
how did that test your heart you know
cuz I'm sometimes I you know I feel like
I was born with a vasectomy that
disconnected my nuts from my heart and
so I'd love to connect those things a
little bit better because you know I can
feat sometimes it's it's just so hard
literally the lights just went out here
in the studio so if you're on YouTube
that's just because uh [ __ ] who knows
why but you guys actually since the
lights just went out here it's a perfect
time to to listen to this song shine by
Bishop Gunn
we'll see you guys hopefully on Thursday
if not we'll we'll do the follow up to
the calls for next week but call in
leave thoughts on on that topic and or
anything that we talked about you know
thinking about Kanye talking about
perception you know anything we talked
about man this is our conversation so
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far my oh
[Music]
and my mind is somewhere else but when I
found it our patch up where it's been
grown now I'm just floating on the
breeze and I'm feeling like these leaves
I must be but it's gonna take
little town for me to slap that pocket
break good yourselves man you probably
deserve
[Music]